today on the matt wall show one of the
most horrific murder cases in modern
history has gotten zero and i really do
mean
zero coverage for the american national
media the reason well the victim is a
white five-year-old child the alleged
killer is a black man
but this case deserves attention and we
will give it attention today
on the show also five headlines
including blm activists claiming now
that looting is okay
because it's a form of reparations and
in our daily cancellation i'll cancel
all the leftists who are currently
celebrating or
over a woman being chosen as biden's vp
apparently these leftists have forgotten
that
women don't exist anymore according to
them so
i'll have to remind them of that uh
rather technical problem today on the
show but first
let's talk about lifelock uh listen you
can't believe everything you
see on the internet in case you didn't
know that especially when you get a
random email that seems suspicious
fraudsters have been trying to
capitalize these days by
sending messages through social media
and emails trying to get
consumers to fall for a scam that uses
cash app
the message the way it works is it
offers free money via the app
to help people through a difficult time
however the link is in the message is
fraudulent
and malicious and it could steal money
it could steal your personal information
uh and this is just one example of a
scam there are many more scheduling
millions of scams out there and
you might think you're too smart to fall
for it but scammers have ways of
getting your info no matter how smart
you think you are that's why you need to
protect yourself with lifelock because
the fact is
every day we might not want to think
about it but we put our information at
risk
on the internet you could miss certain
identity threats just by
you know if you're monitoring your
credit or something like that you're
going to miss
some stuff good thing there's lifelock
lifelock detects a wide range of
identity threats like your social
security number being for sale in the
dark web
you also have access to a dedicated
restoration specialist if uh if you do
have a problem then you're gonna have
that resource
and that's gonna help you uh in in one
of those cases
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses lifelock can see threats that
you might miss on your own join now
and save up to 25 off your first year go
to lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com walls for 25
off um now we have to
talk about this horrible case it's a
story that
shocks the conscience even amid all of
the
death and atrocity in the world it
stands out and
sticks with you five-year-old cannon
hint was murdered in cold blood this
past sunday
while out riding a bike in front of his
father's house the alleged killer
darius sessoms was
witnessed walking right up to the child
putting the gun to his head
pulling the trigger an execution point
blank range of a small child in front of
his sisters who were also playing
outside
at the time sessoms a demon spawn
straight from hell if he is guilty of
this crime initially fled the scene but
was caught
hours later it's still not known why he
allegedly
committed this unspeakable atrocity
though at one level of course it doesn't
matter it's a hideous evil
no matter the motivation behind it but
you can't help but ask why
when you hear about something like this
especially when you realize that sesames
was the next door neighbor
uh to the child's father and according
to some witnesses he had just been over
for dinner the night before so i suspect
there will never be a completely
coherent
answer to the why question and this is
the very definition of a of a senseless
act
but now a beautiful joyful child has
been
taken from the world most importantly
from his family from his parents
and the hole that is left in his absence
will never be filled that's one thing we
know for sure
here's another thing we know for sure
the name
cannon hinnant would be known across the
country and the name
darius sessoms reviled the world over if
the races were reversed
a story of a white man running up to a
black child
and executing him while he rode his bike
would be front page news for weeks
and we all know this and there would
almost certainly be rioting spurned on
in part by the incense
incessant coverage we know that instead
this story has gotten almost
no coverage by the american national
media and when i say no coverage i
really mean
no coverage i think a visual here will
be instructive as of this morning
when i last checked a search for canon
hinnons turned up
zero results with the new york times
zero with the washington post
reuters yahoo news nbc news
abc news a search on cnn also turned up
no results though google does direct you
to an article
by w-r-a-l a local news channel in north
carolina
apnews.com does have a little blurb
about it but you have to really search
to find it it's a few sentences long and
of course doesn't make any mention of
the races of the people involved
now i should know i should note that in
the next few days
some of these outlets may follow suit
and and do what the ap did and put up
their own little blurbs if they feel
some pressure for not having covered it
they may just cover the base to say they
did and then move on quickly
or maybe they won't maybe they'll say
nothing at all uh either way the point
is clear this is not something
they want to talk about so far with this
case
we have one of the most thorough and
remarkable blackouts of a story that
i've ever seen certainly since gosnell
anyway
now it's easy to anticipate the excuses
that will be
offered and in some cases have already
been offered for this outrageous
disparity
it'll be claimed that for example
canon's execution is not newsworthy
because it was carried out by a civilian
not an agent of the state
not an agent of the state but ammar
arbory was was killed by civilians so
was trayvon martin
they're both household names it'll be
argued that
this crime wasn't racially motivated
which is supposed to make it less
relevant to the general public but even
if i agreed with the premise
that non-racially motivated crimes
aren't as relevant
and i don't agree with that presence uh
with that with that uh
premise but even if i did and even if
it's true that canon's murder wasn't
motivated by race
and we don't know that at this point
this argument still doesn't wash
because michael brown was not a racially
motivated killing neither was freddie
gray or eric garner or george floyd
or really any of the famous homicide or
alleged homicide cases from the last
decade or so
none of them have had any established
and proven link to racism
yet these victims are all also household
names
now as a last-ditch attempt at
obfuscation it'll be said that
well this crime isn't on video thus
making it less sensational and giving
less
viral potential to it um and it's sad if
murder is looked at
that way these days as content to be
consumed
but i can see that this is in fact how
the media views the subject
but there was no video of trayvon martin
there was no video of
freddie gray and on the other side i
could think of plenty of sensational
murders
that were caught on video yet yet
receive very little coverage
daniel shaver the white arizona man
killed by cops while on his knees
begging for his life
the worst cop shooting that that has
been caught on video hands down
or how about brittany hill the the black
chicago mother gunned down by gang
members while holding her baby
it's one of the most shocking crimes
ever to be caught on camera and yet
very little media interest in either of
these cases
there simply is no explanation for the
way these various incidents are treated
other than the most disgraceful and
infuriating one
the national media is specifically
interested
in fueling a certain racial narrative
and they will make the intentional
editorial decision to blacklist
or downplay any story that interferes
with it
brittany hill was ignored because she
was killed by men with the wrong
color skin the silence around canon
hinton's name is
even more deafening because he was
killed by a man with the wrong color
skin
while also himself having the wrong
color skin
we cannot be so jaded that we don't stop
to really focus on this and consider it
for the horror and the outrage that it
is the national media doesn't care
that canon hinnant died
was killed and doesn't want you to care
because he was white it is that
straightforward that sick
that evil there is no way around it it
is the truth it is undeniable
the lesson that we take from this i
think is crucial
our reality is curated we live in the
information age but
the information is not the same thing as
knowledge even less is it is it
perspective even less is it wisdom
to have information to be informed is
merely to be made aware of certain
events and certain facts
and perhaps only in bits and pieces but
we have confused information with
knowledge which means that the people
giving us information
also give us the illusion of knowledge
they sift through the events of modern
society pulling bits from here and bits
from there
presenting pieces of different puzzles
but never the full picture
and then we many of us anyway as
americans take all of those pieces and
imagine that we
know something about the world so if the
national media only ever tells us about
white on black killing
and only very carefully selected facts
about those killings
and they flat out refuse to acknowledge
the existence of black on white killing
or if they have to acknowledge it only
in a dismissive way and certainly never
ever ever in the context of any kind of
larger trend then we'll begin to think
that we know something and what we know
we think is that america is a racist
country where black people are being
hunted and killed
and the reverse almost never happens
because white people are protected by
their
privilege and by the racist institutions
that elevate them while oppressing
everybody else
this is the picture the media wants to
present wants us to see
by forcing a bunch of random pieces from
other puzzles together
the narrative is all that matters it is
the prime directive the only thing that
is ever considered when deciding
what not to cover what to cover and how
to cover it
and that is why canon hinnant despite
being a precious and innocent young
child
savagely cut down in broad daylight
while riding his bike
looking forward to starting kindergarten
that is why he will not be memorialized
or mourned over or talked about the way
that george floyd was
that doesn't change the fact this is a
great
unimaginable tragedy and it is an
injustice that commit that commands our
attention
no matter what cnn says or more
precisely doesn't say
about it let's go to our five headlines
[Music]
before we talk about these you know it's
really important to be prepared before
an emergency hits because once the
emergency is upon you it's a little bit
late to get repaired there
then and that's why you need ready wise
as you probably already know our sponsor
wise company has changed their name to
ready-wise
now is a better time than any to be
prepared with long-term nutritional food
options
ready wise has options meal options like
emergency meals freeze-dried fruits
and vegetables for convenience they also
have new adventure meals for hiking or
camping
which i really enjoy ready wise meals
are easy to prepare all you gotta do is
add water
they have a very long shelf life uh and
uh and it
they're also affordable so readywise is
making it affordable and
not just that also let me let me add the
meals taste good ready-wise uses the
finest ingredients and latest food
preparation technology
to ensure optimal taste and freshness so
you're not sacrifice or sacrificing
taste
just because of the convenience that
comes with it every recipe is crafted by
a team of chefs to provide a nutritional
meal
during critical times each meal is a
combination of both dehydrated and
freeze-dried ingredients
meals are packed into durable
long-lasting pouches designed to keep
the food fresh for up to 25
years and i can tell you that uh the
this is one of the most noticeable
things for me
about ready wise when i have tried it
and i've got i've got a whole stash of
course that i'm that i'm saving for an
emergency but i've tried it as well and
uh
i was blown away by just how good it
tastes as well this week my listeners
can get free shipping at readywise.com
when entering walsh at checkout or by
calling
855-475-3089 ready wise is a 90-day
no questions asked return policy so
there's no risk taking the initiative to
get yourself and your family prepared
today
that's readywise r-e-a-d-y
promo code walsh to get free shipping
today okay number one kamala harris is
joe biden's vp
pick this is exciting news folks i mean
i don't really care but some people do
so
uh it's exciting for some people i'll
have more to say about this in the daily
cancellation for now let me just echo
the sentiments uh
expressed by other people that this pick
seems like perhaps the worst of all
worlds for joe biden
she's from a state that biden was
already going to win
um she doesn't have an enthusiastic fan
base
she's hated by a lot of people left of
center and right of center a bit like
hillary in that regard so i'm not sure
what what the
what the upside is here other than the
fact that she checks the box
she's a minority woman she checks the
box and since biden announced ahead of
time
that he's gonna pick a woman and that he
especially wants to pick a minority
woman well
he can't claim now although he's going
to try to but
can't really claim credibly that she got
the job because she was the best fit for
it she he already announced that he was
he was ruling out most people because of
their demographics
um so this is a this is a a check the
box type of pick and he told us that
ahead of time
but as i said there'll be more to say
about that in a daily cancellation
number two the country of new zealand
one of the most
remote inhabited land masses on earth
a tiny island nation with a few million
residents a few airports a few
international airports
and with its closest neighbors being
australia the most sparsely inhabited
continent on earth
and antarctica an uninhabited continent
um so we're talking about that new
zealand just to be specific that's new
zealand we're talking about here okay
not any other
and and this country has been put
forward as a coronavirus success story
and a model for the rest of us to follow
and sure we could follow the new zealand
model all we have to do first of all is
is uproot our continent and place it
somewhere in the middle of the pacific i
don't know we do we we need to be
floating out there with no one else
around us uh so that we can even begin
to you know be in the same position as
new zealand
but here's the problem new zealand is
now having a surge of new cases
and in response they're shutting down
their cities again going into lockdown
um considering postponing their election
and there are people flocking to the
grocery stores again panicking uh here's
here's some of that footage watch this
[Music]
now here's the kicker the surge in new
cases that i just mentioned
four people four
in one family and as far as i know none
of the cases are fatal
four people four non-fatal cases
in the entire country and they're
shutting everything down
and panicking like that so what can we
take from that for one thing
they're terrified because they have zero
herd immunity which
which makes them more susceptible which
is a good argument against the lockdowns
but for another this is how new zealand
is handling it
if anyone anywhere gets diagnosed
they panic and shut down their whole
society
and and so when someone puts forth the
new zealand model
that's what they're suggesting we do
that we stay locked down
until there are literally zero cases and
as soon as another case come pops up
again
we shut down again number three a black
lives matter organizer in chicago has
come out in defense of looting
on the basis that it is she says
reparations
take a listen i don't care if somebody
decides to loot a gucci
or a macy's or a nike because that makes
sure that that person eats
that makes sure that that person has
clothes that makes sure that that person
can make some kind of money because this
city obviously doesn't care about them
not only that that's reparations that is
reparations anything they want to take
take it because these businesses have
insurance
they're going to get their money back my
people aren't getting anything anything
you want to take
take it is her quote
imagine as a sane human actually
aligning yourself with
that actually you know being on the same
side
as people who openly state that they
have a god-given right to take anything
they want from anybody
so if you're aligning yourself with
black lives matter the organization
this is what you're aligning yourself
with is that really what you do you
really believe that
you think that people have the right to
just take whatever they want from anyone
um now okay so
first of all we've got a few competing
assertions here looting is okay because
people need the stuff
because they're starving or is it
because they have a right to it because
of its reparations for atrocities that
were committed against other people 150
years ago
it seems like it has to be one or the
other right and either way of course
it's lunacy
and the idea that people have to steal
armfuls of purses and shoes from
designer stores because they're hungry
what are they going to do eat the shoes
what what exactly is happening here
it's again lunacy and it's probably
pointless to spend much time explaining
why this is
because if if you hear an assertion like
that
and you actually find it persuasive
uh there's this there's you you are
so far gone psychologically that there's
probably no argument i could ever
present to you to convince you otherwise
so let's move on number four um there
have been a number of attacks already
launched ads
ads and you know things launched against
the biden harris ticket
all of the attacks warranted some of
them more effective than others let me
give you an example
uh this one just came out this is an
example of a an effective
uh attack against biden harris watch
joe biden kamala harris the most extreme
pro-abortion ticket in american history
and the agenda to prove it
a pro-abortion supreme court and
abortion on demand
even at nine months up to the moment of
birth
all with your tax dollars so extreme
biden and harris believe
babies who survive abortions should be
left to die
disturbing views troubling policies joe
biden and kamala harris are pro-abortion
fanatics
women speak out pact is responsible for
the content of this advertising
i've been saying this forever uh this is
a winner for republicans
exactly what you saw there and this is
true
these are pro-abortion extremists joe
biden is a pro-aborting ship now he
might not really be in his head
you know any i i think he probably knows
in his own mind
that a a child five seconds before birth
is a human being
uh or or you know or five seconds after
conception is also a human being he
probably knows that in his head just
like he knows in his head
that you know that men can't get
pregnant but he's pretending
that he doesn't know these things
because he is beholden to the far left
and uh and camilla harris especially on
these issues really is
authentically a far leftist this is this
is this is a winner
okay to point out that they are
extremists this is not something
supporting you know killing babies fully
developed in the womb
who are viable outside of the womb that
is
not a mainstream position
it's among pro-abortion people it might
be but among
just the general population it is not
and so this is absolutely something that
should be put front and center and i
think that's a great ad okay number five
finally i have to tell you
i was i was really thrilled to see this
article in vice as a member myself of
the arachnophobia community
uh as someone who has that disability
uh i'm tired of being marginalized and
excluded from society and vice is coming
to my defense here's the article it says
spiders are a popular video game monster
they're also an accessibility problem
the developers of grounded which is a
video game i guess made spiders the big
enemy of an
enemy of their new game then suddenly
realized a bunch of people were too
scared to play it
they decided to find a real solution and
then there's this editor's note look at
this
editor's note there are no images of
spiders in this piece because this is a
story about a phobia we have decided to
avoid
including any imagery that might trigger
it
this is sort of like a an anti-trigger
warning it's a trigger warning that
there are no triggers okay great
let's go to the article says when you
first start grounded a stylish new
survival game from rpg developer
obsidian
where shrunken players explore a
backyard full of unexpected dangers the
game asks a surprising question
are you afraid of spiders the game
informs players quote the
the game contains spiders that are often
much larger than the player
if you're super not okay with that you
can enable arachnophobia safe mode in
the accessibility options
this is a visual only setting that does
not affect gameplay or difficulty
um and from there it's it's uh and going
back to the articles it's from there
it's super easy to jump in and move the
slider to change
and deform the look of the game's
spiders from something monstrous into
blobs with two bulging eyes
a small but important touch you don't
even have to see the original design for
a spider the game forces the player to
enable
spider preview
and then uh okay this just this article
goes on for a long
a long long time this is a very long
article
and uh talking about the accessibility
problem
of uh for arachnophobes people of the
iraq community
iraq not iraq that's what we call
ourselves
i just decided and the problem is we're
excluded from games that have scary
spiders
and this is something that has really
plagued me especially as an avid
gamer myself but fortunately video game
developers are finally addressing the
problem and i'm very grateful for that
but this is obviously this is what i
want to say this is only a first step
yes we can eradicate spiders from video
games
but what about on the rare occasion that
a gamer leaves the house
you know what if it's that that that uh
monthly or bi-monthly journey out of the
house
there are spiders everywhere outside
have you seen outside it's horrifying
there's little bastards spinning their
webs everywhere no respect for your
personal space
everywhere you go they're trying to
catch you in their webs they're trying
to you know
crawl into your ear lay eggs in your
brain
this kind of stuff happens so my issue
is
i am not able to participate in
existence
really i'm not able to participate in
life in general
at least not to the fullest extent
because spiders are out there
and they're super scary and they have
too many eyes
just far too many it's weird it's not
right
so something has to be done for my
community so we can really be full
participants in society the video game
is paving the way but what about
everywhere else now here's some
suggestions you could start by
first of all giving us all earplugs so
that the spiders can't get in that'd be
a good
place to start we could talk about you
know
some kind of plan to hunt down all the
spiders and exterminate them a genocide
of spiders if if you will
or in lieu of that uh i mean listen if
you want to just
give me some money for my pain and
suffering
i don't know maybe 10 15 million a year
from taxpayers that might help ease my
fears and uh heal my wounds
before the spiders can crawl in so these
are all things we could talk about but
i'm glad
i'm just glad that we are finally having
that conversation it's an important
conversation
speaking of important conversations
let's move on to our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we're
gonna be canceling everybody on the left
celebrating the camila harris vp
pick because they can't celebrate it
doesn't make sense for them to celebrate
it
because but you see this is a common
problem one of the most prominent
characteristics of leftists in modern
america is their complete inability or
unwillingness
to apply their principles consistently
especially in their personal lives
now you see stark illustrations of this
problem provided for example by the
climate alarmist who warns of an
impending apocalypse but still maintains
a 401k
the pro-abortion zealot who
congratulates a pregnant woman despite
believing her to be infested by a
subhuman parasite
of course there are also the well-worn
examples of the socialist tweeting about
the pitfalls of capitalism on his iphone
um the progressive politician preaching
about the evils of guns while flanked by
a squadron of armed security
so all of that it seems that you know if
not for cognitive dissonance
many on the left would not have any
cognition at all
nowhere is this dynamic more obvious
and glaring than in the arena of gender
leftist gender ideology contradicts
itself in so many places that you feel
yourself
nearly going insane just trying to make
sense of all of it and i think that's by
design by the way
it's not one coherent theory but a
chaotic web of declarations and
doctrines each asserting itself
without any apparent awareness of the
others one example
at random we're told that sexual
orientation
is immutable cannot be changed right
we're also told that gender is fluid
and can easily be changed these two
things
cannot be true at the same time if a gay
man decides to identify as a woman then
then either we must say that he is no
longer gay since he's now a woman
attracted to a man
or he is not actually a woman if he's no
longer gay then sexual orientation can
be changed if he's not actually a woman
then gender is not fluid
see there are only three options here
either sexual orientation cannot be
changed
and neither can gender or sexual
orientation
can be changed and so can gender or
sexual orientation can be changed but
gender cannot be changed
any of those are logically possible
though only one is scientifically and
factually correct
but the theory that sexual orientation
is immutable while gender is fluid
is a logical impossibility
somebody making such a claim might as
well defend the inherent roundness of
rectangles or the fundamental
dryness of water it is logically
contradictory
it cannot be true the leftist confusion
about gender and about what their
own view on the subject is supposed to
be has been especially on display ever
since joe biden of course announced
camila harris like we talked about as
his pick for vice president
um there are other you know funny and
hypocritical things about the pick too
of course such as the fact that
harris will now be working under and
subordinate to a man that you
tearfully denounced as a racist not even
a year ago
but the greater point is that the
media's ecstatic reaction to a woman vp
pick is belied by the rather serious
problem that women don't technically
exist according to leftist ideology
according to them the word woman has no
discernible meaning
a woman is not necessarily a person with
xx chromosomes and female reproductive
organs
a woman is not defined by anything
physical nor
nor neurological nor psychological nor
behavioral
a woman is not defined by anything
which which is to say that a woman isn't
anything in particular
woman by the light of the left's
philosophy is an
arbitrary concept it has no substance it
is not objective
it can mean anything and be anyone
if you think i'm overstating the case
here then just approach any leftist
currently extolling the woman
vice presidential nominee and simply ask
them what they mean when they say woman
they will not be able to answer the
question
they cannot define the word and i mean
literally cannot
their ideology won't allow it now if you
do pose this question
you know the eternal question that i
have been posing to leftists for years
now
the most likely response will be a
deflection accusing you of being a
transphobe or whatever but
you know of course not actually
answering the question you may however
be presented with some kind of attempt
at an answer
so let's go through a couple here's a
common one uh one that i've heard many
times
a woman is an adult human female which
yes this part is correct
this this is the actual answer you win
the prize congratulations adult human
female that's what a woman is
but then they'll continue an adult human
female or
anyone who identifies as an adult human
female
now our coherent and correct definition
has been thrown into chaos
because this definition is just another
way of saying that a woman is an adult
human female
or not an adult human female woman has
no definition if that is a definition
a thing cannot be what it is and also
what it isn't this is like saying that a
tree is is a tree or anything that looks
like a tree
so a drawing of a of a tree actually
isn't a drawing of a tree because it is
the thing that it's a drawing of
that makes no sense a similar problem
for people who say
trans women are women okay then why do
you call them trans
what does the trans part denote is there
in fact some
notable difference between trans women
and non-trans women
if so then the two groups are
fundamentally different but if you say
they are not
fundamentally different then um then it
doesn't make any sense to differentiate
them the way that you already do in the
ways
in the way that you refer to them so
none of this makes any sense you might
also be told that
words like woman and man are on a
spectrum
okay then tell me about this spectrum
what is on either side of this spectrum
define the people who exist on the
extreme
ends of the woman side of the man's side
if someone is on the spectrum between
man and woman what does that mean
between what and what so you can't
escape the definition problem by talking
about spectrums
if the spectrum takes us from one
undefinable thing
to another undefinable thing then it is
not a spectrum it is more like a black
hole where all sense and reason and the
very laws of science break down
into nothingness so what exactly does a
man mean when he says
i identify as a woman what is a woman
is a woman in the end just anyone who
enjoys feminine things or dresses in a
feminine way well
that can't be it because we can't define
feminine until we have defined the word
woman the word
the definition of feminine is hinged on
the definition of woman
also this definition would turn a lot of
women into non-women and a lot of
non-women into women
besides the left has been trying to
break down the societal constructs of
feminine versus masculine for years now
surely you can't go from not all women
should be expected to be feminine to
the only defining characteristic of
womanhood is femininity
so what is a woman they have no answer
as leftists though they are obliged to
celebrate
the achievements of women even as they
are obliged to also deny the objective
existence of women
this is the paradox that we are expected
to pretend we don't notice
but we should notice it because it
reveals the basic incoherence of leftist
gender
ideology it is it's not see this is what
i want people to understand
it's not just scientifically wrong it is
scientifically wrong
it is also logically impossible what
they are the
the things that they are are asserting
and contending make no logical sense
and that's the most important part of
this
um and because of all of that
they're cancelled who am i can i guess
the left in general i'm cancelling
sort of redundant i cancel them every
day but just to be clear
cancelled again on the matt wall show
and we're going to leave it there on
that note
have a great day everybody godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
is turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton